it's seven o'clock this is Sky News
breakfast our top stories
I have lost my best friend heartbroken
family and friends paid tribute to a 23
year old man stabbed to death in a
Birmingham nightclub
two people are still being questioned
over the death of beautician Ellie
Edwards killed during a shooting at a
pub in Liverpool
America's storm of a lifetime 65 people
are now known to have died but it's
feared that number will rise
a fresh round of strikes are underway
this morning border guards are walking
out at major airports and some train
services are also hit
data seen by Sky News suggests that over
1 million women caught up in a pension
payments trap a living in debt
Sky News has been told that that despite
China's easing of covert restrictions
hospitals are overwhelmed with the
numbers of patients dying from the virus
call for new sanctions on Iran labor
says a Crackdown is needed on those
suppressing protests in the country
I'm here in Surrey as the National Trust
warns that this year's extreme weather
conditions could become the new Norm
unless measures are taken to tackle
climate change
support Marcus rashford plays his part
as Manchester United moved within a
point of the top four in the Premier
League
and joining me at 7 45 to review this
morning's papers at the broadcasters and
journalist Thomas Copeland and bidisha
mamasa
[Music]
very good morning police have named the
23 year old man stabbed to death on the
dance floor of a nightclub in Birmingham
Cody Fisher a semi-professional
footballer was attacked just before
midnight on boxing day detectives are
trying to identify a group of people
suspected of carrying out the attack in
a statement Cody's family said they have
broken our hearts Sky's Becky Johnson
reports
Cody Fisher was a young footballer who
was on a night out with friends when he
was stabbed to death
he was on the dance floor in a nightclub
in Birmingham when he was attacked
at his Club Stratford town the players
and chairman are in Shock he's a
talented footballer but more importantly
he was a lovely person he's just a
lovely lady cheeky smile on his face in
a blonde hair blue eyes he didn't have a
bad bone such a good kid
just shouldn't have happened yet
that's so close to these kids at this
level yeah
and they just need a chance don't they
and then they
they go out
Pharmacy and they don't come home
it's got a change in it
it's got a change
pictures from inside the crane nightclub
in digbeth show a packed Dance Floor on
boxing day night it was that the evening
was coming to an end that Cody was
fatally stabbed staff described Mayhem
as people ran out of the club officers
were called at quarter to midnight but
Cody was pronounced dead around half an
hour later
there were hundreds of people in this
nightclub and police say they want to
speak to anyone who saw what happened or
has footage on their mobile phones
some people who are at the club have
described seeing a group of young men
who were looking for trouble other
clubbers have criticized Security checks
at the event police say Cody was
approached by a group of people and then
stabbed but no one knows why he was
targeted one of his family has paid
tribute saying they have broken our
hearts I've lost my best friend my
family and I are asking for privacy and
respectfulness at this heartbreaking
time
the nightclub say their thoughts are
with the victim and his family and
friends an ad that they're working
closely with West Midlands police
they've canceled their event on New
Year's Eve
the football clubs where Cody has played
over the years have all been sharing
their shock and sadness
this promising young footballer now the
latest innocent victim of Senseless
violence
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham
meanwhile two people are still being
questioned a merseyside over the death
of 26 year old Ellie Edwards in a pub on
Christmas Eve The Beautician who was
having a night out with friends is not
believed to have been the target of the
attack a man who was injured in the
attack remains in a critical condition
in hospital
65 people are now known to have died
across North America in one of the
continent's worst winter storms in
decades and for some areas there's even
more extreme weather on the way
forecasters say flash floods are
expected in the U.S Pacific Northwest
and California and some areas could see
another 12 inches of snow with residents
warned to stay at home over the weekend
an estimated 250 000 homes and
businesses experienced blackouts
although power has been steadily
restored
almost 4 000 U.S flights were canceled
on Monday with delays expected to
continue over the coming days
U.S President Joe Biden has approved an
emergency declaration in New York state
allowing Federal support for areas such
as Erie County and its main city of
Buffalo our U.S correspondent James
Matthews reports
in Upstate New York they're still
testing the depth of this crisis these
are pictures from Buffalo with streets
eagerly empty as the city waits for the
snow to subside
there have been dozens of fatalities and
the number is expected to rise the
clear-up is in part a casualty count it
is uh painful uh to find members of your
community that are deceased are those
that are deceased uh actually uh on
streets in our community who are trying
to walk out during storm conditions got
disoriented and passed away out in the
street tens of thousands of people
remained without power for yet another
day in New York state President Biden
pledged federal funds for affected areas
as more snow was forecast they have been
out there talking to them personally
about their experiences going into homes
going into vehicles and and too many
tragic times of finding people who did
not survive the experience and I want
them to know that we know that is
difficult work to do and they're
grieving inside as we all are for the
families who are getting the horrible
heartbreaking news that their loved ones
succumb to the storm over the last day
or two I want people to understand
there's a lot of roads that are
completely blocked right now that have
no access whatsoever
and people are trying to drive into on
these roads or trying to get into these
neighborhoods and they can't
please
please you heard the mayor beg I'm
begging stay home
travel chaos has continued through
Christmas and Beyond this was the scene
at San Diego airport where the baggage
was going nowhere and neither were
passengers canceled flights have
stranded thousands across the country
these are pictures from Buffalo as the
Buffalo Bills football team and staff
dug out their vehicles it provided one
measure of snowfall delivered by the
Arctic blast though ultimately the storm
that straddled Christmas will be defined
by its destruction and death
James Matthews Sky News in Washington
in other news a new round of strikes
gets underway this morning members of
the tssa Union at Great Western Railway
and West Midlands trains are staging
24-hour walkouts and there's a new
strike of UK border guards at major
airports and some ports too even before
today's border four strike there was
disruption at Lille at the French
Eurostar station last night inbound
London commuters were delayed for more
than three hours with many complaining
of unmanned order Force stations and
long queues
the NHS says it is on track to eliminate
hepatitis C in England by 2025. Health
Chiefs say this is thanks to a five-year
contract for an antiviral drug and a
dedicated find and treat campaign to
drive down cases in vulnerable
communities
some hospitals in China are said to be
overwhelmed by the numbers of people
dying from covid and that's despite the
country's recent easing of its tough
restrictions well Sky News has spoken to
some of the doctors involved who paint a
picture of Chaos in some of the
hospitals in the country our Asia
correspondent Helena Smith joins us live
now from Beijing hello to you Helena of
course covered restrictions have been
lifted very quickly in China for a
population of 1.4 billion people explain
to us what you're hearing in terms of
the pressure that that's piling on the
Health Service
while it's causing an immense amount of
pressure on the Health Service and
trying to figure out just how much and
where is an incredibly difficult task in
China because these things are really
veiled in secrecy there are simply not
the official numbers being released
anymore daily case numbers are not being
released and death numbers well we're
getting sort of one or two or three a
day but we're talking about a population
where hundreds of millions of people are
likely now infected that's actually
according to official leaks from
government documents so the numbers of
deaths that are officially being
announced simply don't tally up with
what is almost certainly happening so at
Sky News we've been reaching out to
doctors and nurses and trying to speak
to them and trying to get a picture of
what is going on and three of them have
spoken to us albeit on an anonymous
basis and the picture they paint is
really of very chaotic scenes within the
hospital one Doctor Who's based in the
northern city of shenyen he says that of
the patients that he's caring for in the
most uh the most seriously ill patients
in intensive care roughly fifty percent
of those patients are going on to die
from the disease he talks about the
emergency department being packed with
people being dozens of times quote
dozens of times busier than it would
normally be he talks as well about the
ratio of patients to medical staff
previously would have been about four or
five patients to one doctor now about 10
patients per doctor others speaking of
ambulances they're simply not being
enough ambulances around to Ferry all
the sick people to hospital another
doctor spoke about the fact that almost
all of the nurses have contracted covert
themselves meaning there just aren't
enough staff on the ward to help people
people have been asked to work while
they're sick and others are doing days
multiple days of shifts in a row to try
and deal with the pressure that those
departments are under so really painting
a very difficult picture indeed remember
the covert restrictions here were
incredibly strict really for the entire
duration of the pandemic and then they
were very suddenly lifted about three
weeks ago now and the virus has simply
ripped through the population here as I
said we just don't know how many
infections there are but this is a very
large population with low levels of
natural immunity because that herd
immunity just hasn't built up here and
the vaccinations here are less effective
than Western vaccines and then add on to
that the rates of the elderly who are
fully vaccinated is lower than than
really doctors say it should be so there
are a lot of factors that mean that
people are getting very sick here in
China and and seemingly they are dying
uh it just albeit we just don't know
those figures officially
okay Helena we appreciate your updates
thank you
our labor is calling for new sanctions
against Iran for its brutal repression
on people taking part in those protests
in the country it's now a hundred days
since the protests began and the party
is calling for the government here to
Target individuals and organizations
with sanctions well joining me now is
our political correspondent Murray
Aurora good morning to you Mari what is
it that labor is calling for
morning Sally well the labor party are
calling for a very specific type of
sanctions on individuals and
organizations so not functioning in the
entire country but sanctioning
individuals and organizations that have
links to or connections to the
oppression of Iranian citizens notably
protesters we saw just over the weekend
seven Brits arrested their dual citizens
so they have dual Iranian citizenship as
well now they were arrested on Sunday by
the Revolutionary guard we've also had
other kind of Acts of resistance just
this week earlier we had two female
chess players Iranian chess players
choosing to play not wearing their
headscarves as well and as you say
because this marks a hundred days for
this protest these are actually the the
largest protests we've seen in Iran
since the revolution in 1979 so very
very significant but also the labor
party they're calling for these
sanctions but they're also calling for
the
urgent kind of getting going of the UN
Human Rights council's investigation
into crimes committed by the Iranian
regime as well as the calling for two
things and also David Lammy he's spoken
he's given us a comment and he said
there's killings and oppression by the
Iranian regime against protesters is
appalling he said the Iranian regime
needs to be held accountable for the
crimes they've committed but the issue
here is sanctions are always quite
politically delicate sanctions are very
much one diplomatic tool in the Arsenal
of diplomacy they're not a silver bullet
at all and I think these types of
sanctions specifically targeting
individuals and organizations means that
you're not punishing an entire
population or an entire country for the
crimes or the actions of individuals and
organizations but also it avoids any
kind of clashes with broader foreign
policy as well so they can be quite
convenient in that way nonetheless I
think some people are always worried
about how much of a deterrent affect
their going to have and will they
actually deter people from acting in the
same way in the future if it's not on a
wider scale so we'll just have to see
but No One Believes that these types of
sanctions are a kind of a cure for the
issues in Iran but nonetheless I think
the labor party are hoping to put
pressure on the government and therefore
these sanctions could then put pressure
on the Iranian regime okay Maori for now
thanks very much
so staying on that story it's 100 days
into the Iranian protest what is the
situation in the country well joining me
now is executive director if Iranian and
Kurdish women's rights organization and
women's rights activist Diana Nami
thanks so much for joining us this
morning 100 days of protests
they show no sign of ending do they
what's the latest in terms of what
you're hearing uh it is significant it
is a very very important event After the
revolution in
1997 uh in 1979 sorry uh we never had
this length of the Revolution to
continue for 100 days it is very very
important and it is giving hope to so
many people and to end a very brutal and
dictatorship regime uh in the in the in
the world I have to say
now in terms of what we know about what
is happening inside the country only
only a small amount of information is
getting out via social media or other
means it's potentially a glimpse of what
is exact what is actually happening when
it comes to the extent of the protests
and the treatment of the protesters what
are you hearing about what's happening
yes of course the because of the uh
internet uh Banning in Iran so the news
is not coming out as much as we want but
we can see and hear that the uh
you know people has been in the street
for this uh 100 years and they say there
is no go back at all and we have to go
until we topple this regime this uh very
uh tyranny regime and
thousands of people has been in the
street all this time and it has it has
you know like any Revolution it has ups
and downs there are days that the
situation is a bit calmer and there are
days that more young people and more
people are coming to the street or they
do lots of strikes especially the uh
strike from from fabrics and from a
factories it is very important but
during this 100 Years A Hundred Days
government has not been stopped they try
to oppress the uh the this demonstration
and this revolution as much as they
could and they arrested more nearly 20
000 people so far they arrested so many
people that prisons are full and they
turned many of the schools to prison at
the moment they executed uh more than I
have to say that they killed more than
500 people so far and we can see every
day the kidnapping of young people and
they torture them they rape them they
killed them and they threw their body in
the rivers or through them in the
mountains or in the streets of places
that people don't know them and it take
days for their family to identify their
body and in some cases actually today
even government empty data you know take
out their organs from their body and
they give they give the body back to the
family without their organs in that this
regime is so brutal uh they killed so
many children and what can I say it's
important the continuation of this
demonstration the continuation of the
Revolution despite all this oppression
people in a uh every day when you know
in Iran we have got something we call a
chiller that means 40 days after the
death it says of any person it is a kind
of memorial service again for the uh
that people and every Chiller after
every 30 40 days people also coming to
the street and they shouting against
government they are calling for the
government to to be uh to Tuple and they
are fighting to have the human rights
women's rights equality to stop all the
Discrimination to stop all this
execution and this revolution up you
know continued to have the slug and
women's life Freedom which is very
important and become a slogan all over
the world and this is very shiny about
this Iranian Revolution that women so
far has been the
the lead of this uh
of this Revolution and that has women
has been and women's rights has been so
much respected and accepted by people in
Iran by men and by everyone which is
very significant in my opinion okay in
light of all that Diana just very
briefly if I may given the oppression uh
that protesters are under in the country
but also the ongoing protesters show no
sign of ending how do you see this
ending
I think this process has no ending it
started something that as I say it's no
way to go back but it's all the way to
go forward and the slogan now people
wanted to turn down this regime and I
think it it may delay I am not saying
that it's happened in this week or next
week but I am saying definitely it will
happen in the next uh
next few months let's say which is very
important in my opinion it will you know
end it will end this regime and it will
be the start of a Renaissance not just
in Iran but in Middle East so just very
just very quickly to clarify you think
that the Iranian regime could be toppled
in the next couple of months
because what I am hoping I'm hoping it
will be there less than a year
definitely it is what I am hoping
fascinating stuff we really appreciate
your Insight Diana thank you so much
thank you so much thank you for helping
me
now the National Trust is warning that
extreme weather will become the new Norm
in the UK and it's putting plans in
place to protect nature and Wildlife
well Skies Matthew Thompson is at Box
Hill in Surrey one of the national
trust's most popular Estates good
morning to you Matthew very interesting
isn't it that the National Trust is
throwing their voice uh behind the
climate change cause what are they
saying
very strongly so this is part of the
national trust's annual review of
weather and nature and it comes as you
rightly say with a pretty Stark warning
that their fears are that the extreme
weather events of the last year from
records summer temperatures to freezing
Winters could become the new norm and
pose significant challenges for wildlife
the summer of course that just went was
the joint hottest on record we saw
record temperature of 40.3 degrees
reached in July and although it does
seem slightly counter-intuitive to be
saying this from underneath an umbrella
much of the country believe it or not is
still in drought because months of low
rainfall have simply failed to replenish
what was lost to the heat over the
summer that clearly has serious
implications for a variety of wildlife
wildfires devastated much of the country
particularly on National Trust land in
part places like the southwest of
England that has caused Devastation to
the habitat attacks of a number of rare
species of lizard of snake of butterfly
for example the low rainfall has proven
challenging for the breeding cycles of
rare species of toads of bats of
butterflies and all manner of other
animals now all is not entirely lost the
National Trust says that through its
conservation work it is able to mitigate
some of the damage for example at their
hole in the coat estate in Somerset they
reintroduced beavers and beavers
amazingly simply by their presence and
the engineering Works they construct
keep the water levels much higher than
they would otherwise be that therefore
keeps at nearby Woodland wet and Lush
and better maintained but the point is
that is very much damage limitation and
the real fear from The National Trust is
that the cycle of extreme weather events
that we've seen in 2022 are a blueprint
really for what comes in the future and
that potentially causes some serious
challenges for both nature for wildlife
and for the National Trust
certainly does Matthew we appreciate the
update oh take care out there don't blow
away we'll see you later go get a cup of
tea
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet this is our climate dashboard
and the right half of the screen shows
you how the UK's power is currently
being produced
on the top left you can see how much
warmer the Earth is now than in 1880
that's when modern record keeping began
and finally if you have a look in the
bottom left the total amount of CO2
emissions that's in millions of tons and
those are live data
speaking of weather let's have a look at
how things are looking today
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
it'll be unsettled this week with spells
of wind and rain
Southern parts will be fairly mild wet
and windy at first today as we've just
seen while the north will be mostly fine
but chilly with a patchy Frost and
Shetland will be wet rain in the South
will spread across many parts this
morning with brighter skies and a
scattering of showers following to
Ireland but Scotland will stay mostly
dry and sunny a very good morning you're
watching Sky News breakfast our top
stories the family and friends of 23
year old Cody Fisher have paid tribute
to him after he was named as the victim
of a fatal knife attack in a Birmingham
nightclub
while two people are still being
questioned over the death of beautician
Ellie Edwards killed during a shooting
at a pub in Liverpool
a call for new sanctions on Iran labor
says a tougher Crackdown is needed on
those suppressing protests in the
country
many of the three million women caught
up in a pensions trap are said to be
struggling financially with a third
saying they are in debt the women born
in the 50s have been campaigning because
they claim they were overlooked when the
government increased the state pension
age to 66 when they were expecting to
claim a pension from the age of 16.
Skies Ashner huronag has the story
after over three decades working as a
carer moira's health began to suffer
begetting her through it was knowing
retirement at 60 was Round the Corner
except what she and 3.8 million women
born in the 50s weren't told was the
state pension age had risen with no time
to prepare she suddenly learned she had
to work for six more years it was
devastating absolutely devastating
physical and mentally it was really
struggling really struggling to work and
also lots of my friends died at 60 so
they never got their pension so not only
that I'm thinking am I ever going to see
this pension because am I going to live
to be 66 nobody knows
after years of campaigning last year the
Parliamentary Ombudsman found these
women should have been given more notice
for women like Moira it could have made
a huge difference to their lives data
shared exclusively with Sky News found
almost a third of women affected are in
debt eighty percent of those surveyed
said they had suffered financial
hardship by the delay in finding out the
age of retirement had moved and over 220
000 women affected have died without
answers many of them Angela knew
personally and it's for them she
continues to fight for answers the
government has never really engaged with
us guy oppermann the last pensions
Minister said he last met with com waspy
campaign in 2016
which really is atrocious given that we
have lost so much through government
incompetence the department for work and
pensions says it prioritizes supporting
people to get the help they are entitled
to and point to both the high court and
court of appeal judgments which support
their actions on the issue for a
generation of women their weight for
compensation ticks on as they can't
shake the feeling of Injustice
ashnaharanag Sky News
now the National Trust is warning that
this year's extreme weather conditions
are set to become the norm and it's
worried about the impact that it's
having on its Estates and Wildlife well
joining me now is head of nature
conservation at the National Trust Ben
McCarthy a very warm welcome to you
thank you for joining us at what sort of
National Trust habitats and Wildlife are
most under threat
well we're seeing the impacts of climate
change uh uh impacting all of our
habitats across our state uh in England
Wales Northern Ireland so it doesn't
matter if it's the uh the grasslands of
Southern England or the woodlands of uh
Northern Ireland or the peatlands of uh
Wales the impacts of being seen uh right
across our estate and they're having a
real uh they they they put up a whole
series of challenges for the wildlife in
our care so for example we know that uh
some of the threatened natterjack toads
for example in the in the ponds of
Formby sand dunes uh are drying out
stopping the Toads uh being able to
breed so there's a whole gamut of kind
of examples of of where the impacts are
are being seen
um right in front of our eyes and it's a
real challenge for us to tackle the
challenging weather events which we know
are only going to get worse with the
onset of climate change
and what measures
The National Trust taking to try to
protect some of these species and and
habitats that are being affected well
we're really clear that part of the
solution to both the climate and the
nature crisis is to deliver nature-based
Solutions those are those which are
establishing Woodlands for example which
uh suck out carbon out of the atmosphere
and lock it away in a similar way we're
storing our peatlands does the same
locking away uh carbon in there in their
PT soils they also uh support a whole
range of different wildlife and provide
real benefits to humans by for example
absorbing rain water
and letting it uh and releasing it more
slowly down the catchment reducing flood
risks
now during
um the intense heat waves last summer we
saw wildfires in the UK houses bursting
into flames is the National Trust having
to now consider this when it comes to
protecting your sites yeah we had a
number of uh wildfires across the estate
this year and it is something that we're
expecting to get
um uh only increase so we're managing
that in a number of ways primarily on
places where we've got peat soils which
are part of the solution to the climate
crisis we're busy re-wetting those bogs
those peatlands because wet peatlands
don't burn in other places we're working
with our partners and the Fire Rescue
Services to make sure that we've got
coordinated plans such that we can
respond to any incidences as soon as
possible but one of the kind of weirdly
critical things about Wildfire is
actually recognizing it's a bit of a
misnomer actually most Wild fires are
caused by people things like disposable
barbecues or even litter thrown out of
the window can magnify the sun in the
drought conditions that we had earlier
this year and cause fires and those
fires cause extreme Devastation as you
can see on the screen there
now
of course you're warning today that this
extreme weather is set to become the
norm this is a global issue which
requires a cooperation between
governments what more do you want to see
happen and implemented by the UK
government
so we need to see stronger and faster
action both for the climate and the
nature crisis and here at the National
Trust we're working really hard with our
partners as well as government
departments to try to put in place
robust targets to reduce
um uh the loss of species for example uh
and to allow nature to recover because
that is part of the solution for the
climate and nature crisis
okay Ben McCarthy from The National
Trust we appreciate your time best of
luck with your work thanks very much
let's have a look at today's weather now
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
you'll be unsettled this week with
Spells Of Wind and Rain Southern parts
will be fairly mild wet and windy at
first today while the north will be
mostly fine with chill but chili with
Apache Frost Shetland will be wet rain
in the South will spread across many
parts this morning with brighter skies
and a scattering of showers following to
Ireland but Scotland will stay mostly
dry and sunny it'll be mild generally
but it will be windy and a bit rainy too
in the South recent rain and higher than
average temperatures across the Alps
have brought a significant Avalanche
risk especially to the north and west so
off-peace skiing is generally not
advisable that said Austria has some
good skiing on piece mainly at altitude
France has a good high level has good
high level snow too I should say and the
majority of ski lifts are running there
but artificial snow is still needed on
many of the lower slopes
elsewhere the dolomites in Italy have
some of the best snow having avoided the
recent rain while Switzerland has good
snow altitude with nearly two meters at
sasafe
news snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk on my ski hire in Europe
and with us this morning to review the
newspapers are broadcasters and
journalists Thomas cakeland and badisha
mamata good to see you both again
butisha let's kick off with the article
you pulled out from the Daily Star
interesting isn't it that this warning
from The National Trust today that you
know extreme weather is going to become
the new Norm has even been picked up in
the star today quite strong lines
yes it has and it follows on from your
lovely interview with Ben McCarthy from
The National Trust who every year do a
survey of how the year has gone in terms
of Nature and wither nature and what's
happening with it unsurprisingly the
news has not been very good for the last
few years but they're pointing out that
the seemingly headline grabbing climate
manifestations we've had in the last 12
months are indeed going to become the
new normals so the wet bits are dry the
dry bits are wet the solid bits are
collapsing the bits that should be
liquid are solidifying and the survey is
interesting because it reminds us of the
kind of year that we've had in 2022 if
you cast your mind back to January we
had a very warm and Mild January and
then in February we had flash floods and
heavy rainfall and then a crazy Heat
Wave summer where we topped 40 degrees
for the first time ever and then the
snow snap just before Christmas and now
an oddly mild Chris Christmas and Ben
McCarthy and the rest of the national
trusts have pointed out all the the
micro consequences for the birds and the
bees and the butterflies and of course
the climate emergency isn't just picking
out National Trust properties
unfortunately it doesn't discriminate at
all so they're pointing out that exactly
as he said we need to engage Global
World governments in coming together to
fight Rising temperatures because
as dramatic as it might be and as
interesting as it is to read it on the
headlines it is not good for the planet
to live yeah absolutely even though
those tropical rainstorms and flash
floods that we saw in the summer and of
course mild months in the winter as you
say we we see such uh so regularly now
uh don't we
um to you Thomas the eye page eight
you've pulled out the story that the
Northeast may be the next area to get
its own elected mayor
that's right the government's announcing
a 1.4 billion Pine plan for Devolution
Northeast of England the headline I
suppose is a directly elected mayor
first elections may 2024. this is one of
these proposals that has great potential
and Devolution deals have been
championed by labor and the
conservatives over the last number of
years often kind of put forward as a bit
of a silver bullet to every imaginable
problem a note of caution I think always
against Evolution for devolution's sake
coming from a place like where I am at
the moment in Northern Ireland where the
evolution is very dysfunctional the
devil's in the detail and you need to
look at what are the specific Powers
responsibilities an autonomy that these
divulge jurisdictions have and by the
look of this article they don't appear
to be very expansive at all it lists
adult education budget control local
skills Improvement plans some money for
local rail services for money for
housing and Regeneration all of that
just leads to a situation where
Devolution and Devolution settlements
can become a bit of a talking shop an
extra layer bureaucracy a nice extra
layer of jobs for politicians the big
thing that's always missing from the
evolution I think across the UK is
really critical Revenue raising par
that's the thing that adds in
accountability that's the thing that
adds in responsibility means that
politicians can't always point to
Central governments when they need more
money which invariably they always want
and and ask for and actually give them
some responsibility for raising it as
well so you know this is one of a
problem that you see I think in
Devolution across the entirety of the UK
if we want to do Devolution right we
need to buy into it we need to get
proper pars and and responsibilities
this halfway High system doesn't really
work so we'll see in 2024 and onwards as
more of these deals start to come
through how effective they are but that
would be my major concern okay
interesting stuff Thomas thank you
um badisha The Guardian interesting
story you pulled out former Spice Girl
Mel C has canceled her New Year's Eve
performance in Poland why is that
I'm smiling because Mel C is my favorite
this is actually a very very serious
story Mel C Melanie Chisholm of the
Spice Girls had been set to do a New
Year's Eve performance of a Polish state
TV she's now pulled out of it saying
that matters have been brought to her
attention because of certain issues
which she doesn't clarify which she says
don't quite align with her values and
her beliefs reading between the lines
her fans have said that this is in fact
because of the Polish state uh the
government's attitudes towards LGBT
rights uh it's not illegal to be gay in
Poland but there is no recognition of
same-sex marriage or civil unions and it
is not legal for same-sex couples to
adopt if they want to start a family and
have kids they are not allowed to do
that and in fact Poland ranks very low
on the EU list of what it's like to be
gay uh have gay rights and to not be
discriminated against in daily life in
work in life in family in terms of
values however Polish state TV has
fought back and one of the journalists
from from this broadcaster has now
tweeted out a video of Mel C performing
for Russia in 2018 with a slightly
snarky note saying uh well you know
perhaps Russia aligns with your values
and there's been a statement put out
saying that in fact Mel C has had to
Cave into online comments so it's a very
interesting story about stated values uh
States stated values so of course this
doesn't mean that you have to boycott
your polish friends who are very
pro-lgbtq plus rights but it's about
what does the government represent and
this whole argument around cancellation
and should it be could it be that a
major artist is having to live in fear
of what's going to be said in terms of
their Optics or should they just be
allowed to get on with it and sort of be
a pop star without being touched by
sociopolitical issues yeah it's
interesting isn't it and of course that
Sports personalities suffered at the
same issues in Qatar recently with the
World Cup nevertheless girl power from
melthe there uh let's end on something a
bit lighter shall we Thomas this lovely
article that you pulled out from the
times a 74 year old retired teacher who
failed his 11 plus has just graduated
from University tell us more I love
stories like this they pop up
occasionally so this is a 74 year old
man from Swansea his name's John
Wilshire he's graduated with a master's
degree in environmental Dynamics and
climate change at Swansea University the
age of 74 field is 11 plus managed to
get back on his feet he trained as a
teacher then did a wild study while
while working as a teacher did a a
degree at the open University three
diplomas and there's a great line where
he says his last exam was in 1987 and he
said quote surprisingly some things have
changed since then
Thomas
sorry thanks so much uh for ending on
that we'll see you again next hour
thanks very much
foreign
still to come on Sky News breakfast
we'll have all the latest on that
shocking stabbing in Birmingham on
Boxing Day family and friends pay
tribute to 23 year old Cody Fisher who's
been named as the victim of that attack
in a Birmingham nightclub we will be
live in Birmingham at the top of the
hour with the latest on this story of
that attack on boxing day of course
following that other shooting uh that
shocking attack in liver in merseyside
on Christmas Eve will have the latest on
both
foreign
[Music]